you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is a game
from a 1938 tournament between two
players whose style I really admire
Mikhail Botvinnik is playing the white
side against josé raúl capablanca
- very strategic players are doing
battle in what I feel is one of the best
games out there so let's see whose plan
whose strategy in this game comes with
greater effect so game kicks off with
Bob Phoenix d4 and we enter a
nimzo-indian with Bishop b4 after e3 in
d5 well this d5 move is not so well tied
in with this Bishop b4 move because one
of the things you look to do sometimes
with the nihms oh is and in exchange for
it get or saddle white with CC pawns but
that's not the case in this situation
because after a3 Bishop takes pawn takes
due to this tension this unavoidable
tension between the pawns these C pawns
for white will be undone so what has
occurred as a result of that exchange or
two things one black has given white the
bishop pair and two black has helped
white build the center this Knight pond
becomes now a bishop on and has better
control now of the central point d4
black immediately latches out in the
center with c5 and also opens up a
diagonal for that Queen this tension
between the seen D pawns is immediately
resolved C takes D eat takes D and only
then Bishop d3 this is an important
point because one might think you lose a
tempo by playing here first and then
after D takes C Bishop takes see white
is lost tempo that's true but I think
looking even deeper you'll see that this
is losing to temping - two moves because
in the foreseeable future
there's Queen c7 and there's already
then the threat of C takes D with an
attack on the bishop so this bishop
would likely have to move again to d3
the third time so in short
first resolve the tension between those
pawns and then one the Bishop plays to
d3 it's there to stay black castles
Nighy to and we'll see a significant
difference a big difference between e 2
and F 3 in short by playing to e 2 you
allow yourself as white the possibility
for a central expansion with F 3 and E 4
and we'll see that take shape soon
enough
first off b6 for black black is looking
to get rid of one of the bishops a
typical idea when your opponent has the
bishop pair and it makes all the more
sense since this LightSquared bishop of
these two is the better since it works
well with the resulting pollen structure
pawns on dark the light square bishop
would be the better of the two white
castles black follows through with the
light square bishop exchange the knight
is slightly inconvenienced and also
accessible eventually we'll see a queen
coming out but something was still at
least accomplished there's no longer
that bishop pair Bishop b2 seems a
little bit awkward certainly running
short on good diagonals every wherever
you look there's just these dark pawns
and one might think and this is
something that crossed my mind is to
play something like a 4 and then get the
bishop on this diagonal but there's
something much more deep going on here
the bishop deploys itself to b2 to
reinforce deform as indirect as it may
be it's reinforcing d4 and black a White
has every intention of still following
through with this F 3 E 4 idea so Queen
Queen to d7 has a close eye on that a 4
square and now we see a 4 what white
would like to do is something like Queen
to d3 but I think that this move is
played just so that this Queen cannot be
maybe make use of that a 4 square so it
just rules that out altogether
additionally you might see this pawn be
being used as some spearhead on the
Queen side
what happens in the sent in the center
if we're seeing c5 you're not going to
be seeing a5 if you're seeing however
this type of capture well white can be
recapturing the structure is perfect and
then this idea could take shape why
could maybe still go forward with the
central expansion but something like
minority I guess the lowest form of a
minority attack with a5 can really show
itself so anyhow a forum responds to
Queen d7 route de a very logical half
open file Queen d3 pressure on this
night and now we have a shift in the
pawn structure c4 kind of just slams the
door in the Queen's face but something
is accomplished the Queen has to move a
second time she does stay on this
diagonal stays off the back rank of
course stays on this diagonal because
it's the e4 square that she wants to
support again this is White's idea f3
with E for to follow so because of this
advance white need not worry as much now
about this d4 pawn you have this C pawn
which initially was that Knight pond
that Knight pond is essentially the one
that's now defending that d4 point and
so we're going to be having Knight G 3 F
3 e for all these next moves for white
are geared at getting this advance in
and eventually looking to attack that
black King so a lot of repositioning on
the white side in fact these next
handful of moves the knight is looking
to play to B 3 and then the Queen is
going to be in a spot to pick off this
pawn so this is what we have rook on a 2
e1 following through with these plans
knight c6 Knight g3 Knight a5 and here
we go f 3e for the knight hops into b3
it's a nice post it is obstructing the
a4 point but actually let me retract
that this Knight is maybe not such a
great piece it could actually turn out
to be a very misplaced piece it is it is
getting in the way
of the Queen's communication with a four
but if the attention turns on the
kingside which it will very soon this
night could certainly be offsides
efore Queen takes a 'if I've the night
is hit 97 and now what do you do white
is looking to play on the kingside one
one thing that you could be looking to
to determine that is your pawn structure
starting first at the tail of a pawn
structure and running up towards the
head drawing a line you're pointing in
the direction where you should be
playing in this case the Kings side now
one thing to be aware of is that you
might be tempted to just play f4 but I
feel that that would be allowing black
to do something that's a bit annoying if
f4 this was not the move played the move
that was played was Queen to f2 but pop
quiz what would you do or what move is
may be available to black after the move
f4 if you'd like to pause the video see
if you can figure out a difference
between f4 and Queen to f2 in this
instance okay one of the moves that's
available is nighttime B to c5
exploiting the fact that this Queen is
unprotected if Queen takes Queen Knight
takes the Queen's are off the board the
attack is maybe not going it's probably
not going to be there for white without
the Queen's on the board and not to
mention this Bishop is probably still
struggling to do something constructive
so the Queen's would have to be or the
Queen exchange would have to be avoided
with let's say Queen to e2 and now this
is a much different square if you
compare b3 and d3 the more central d3
this Knight is a giant pest
okay the rook could move and hit the
Queen she runs away there might still be
something in this direction for white
but to give black the possibility of
transferring the night from b3 to d3 is
something that should be avoided and it
is avoided because in this position here
we don't have in the media pond storm
with f4 f5 but rather getting
out of that tactic night b2c five I
believe and now this guy is still
stranded still needs a bunch of moves to
get working so everything is just
charged up here white is looking to do
what exactly open files so first off g6
it rules out Knight f5 and Queen g3
stuff that could have been the threat
and now F for following through f5 this
right here is a very common move to be
seeing if your opponent if you're on the
black side and your opponent is ready to
be in a position to cement not only one
pond on the fifth rank but a second one
something almost always needs to be done
about that and you'll often see the move
f5 employed and that is the move played
right now f5 so what do you do you have
to capture it you have to release
release this potential energy the Brooks
and the Queens you have to open files
are there for a reason they want to play
they want to see the black side of the
board so you capture you definitely
capture doing something such as
assessing this position and saying you
know what I don't want to capture
because I like having a connected pass
pun well that's true connected passed
pawns are a strong thing but look what
you do if you don't capture let's just
I'm going to make a passing rule such as
h3 let's just say flight square if
you're doing something like this if
you're not capturing in other words all
four of these pieces actually forget it
all five pieces are big dummies what are
they going to do in fact after something
like Knight f8 to e6 white has
absolutely nothing and this pond I
believe will have time to just march all
the way down or some type of break
you've bought black a ton of time if
you're not going to be capturing that
should not even be a thought if you have
all these pieces lined up here open the
position up anyhow eat aches eat eggs F
on pass on Knight takes f5 the e-files
ripped open
but Vinick is looking to rip open the F
file as well pair of rooks come out rook
to e8
you do not capture the rook capturing
the rook allow
the Queen to come back to defend it's
not needed instead it's rook to e6
pressure on the knight laterally that's
the thing you look to do after rook is
on an open file where can I position it
so that it's functioning laterally in a
good way and often if you could do that
in your opponent's position all the
better rookie six the Brooks come off
and now the knight is hit as a result
King g7 to defend Queen f4 she's looking
to sneak in by way of let's say that's
c7 square Queen drops back to defend and
now Queen to e5 placing this knight in a
pin and Queen to e7 to defend can you
spot this next move for white it's
really one of the more spectacular ones
out there if you'd like to pause the
video see if you can find the best move
for white ok the move is bishop to a3
very spectacular move deflecting the
Queen away so that an additional tactic
can present itself what tactic is that
exactly this is another pop quiz what
would you do in this position as white
pause the video if you'd like to solve
it okay the best move for white is
Knight to h5 and it's certainly the
follow-up move that white had foreseen
this was all calculated in fact I
believe the remainder of the game
at this point right here was calculated
from Bishop a3 through the rest of the
moves of the game I believe it was all
calculated out so this is what we have
as as it's essentially finishing up now
Bishop a3 Queen takes Knight h5
sacrificing another piece pawn takes
Knight Queen to g5 King f8 Queen takes
Knight with check if you go here it's a
mate and 1/2 and so instead the King of
course goes to g8 and now passed pawns
they need to be pushed east 7 is there
and the only thing that black has left
to try is some perpetual check this
Knight very sad piece it's just the
Queen if any if anything at all that
could maybe save the day
what is tried is Queen c1
a few checks are thrown in the king is
racing up the side of the board
grabbing first upon coming back to each
for eventually getting the G pawn in
there to block and dodging just one more
check after King to h5 black resigns
there's absolutely nothing to do about
the possibility for Queen f8 mate or the
queening of the pond if let's say h6
queen g6 and then queening is going to
be game over so as it stood in this game
after some dodging of checks there the
king walking a little bit of a tightrope
up the h5 up the h-file after king h5
black resigns so that's all for this
video as always I hope you got something
out of it take care bye